هنا في الشارع الممتد من جامعه الاقصى
ويتجه باتجاه الجنوب هذه جامعه الاقصى في
خلفيه الصوره حيث اليات الاحتلال تتواجد
في الاجزاء الشرقيه من هذه الجامعه اضافه
الى ان حركه المواطنين في هذا الشارع كما
تشاهدون في هذه اللحظات باتجاه الجنوب
وباتجاه الشمال حاله صعبه خاصه مع تواجد
اليات الاحتلال في المنطقه لكن برغم ذلك
المواطنون في ظل الصعوبات البالغه
والكبيره هنا ما زالوا يحاولون الوصول الى
هذه المنطقه اما للدخول اليها او الخروج
منها هذا هو نهايه شارع خمسه حيث كانت
قوات الاحتلال اعلم ان هذا الشارع هو
الشارع والممر الذي سيسلكه المواطنون
النازحون باتجاه شارع الرشيد هنا في اقصى
الغرب من محافظه خان يونس والمطل على
سواحل وشواطئ خان يونس كان قد وجه نازحين
للتحرك باتجاه هذه المنطقه والتوجه اما
جنوبا بسلوك هذا الشارع باتجاه مدينه رفع
او شمالا باتجاه دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه
هنا حركه النازحين من الوسط من وسط قطاع
غزه باتجاه الجنوب مستمره حتى الان وهناك
حركه ايضا من المواطنين من مناطق مختلفه
هناك اطلاق نار اطلاق نار في هذه اللحظات
الزوارق الاحتلال الحربيه في هذه اللحظات
قذائف تطلق
الاخر اتجاه عدد من المواطنين الظروف صعبه
والتواجد في هذه المنطقه صعب لذلك لابد من
مغادره هذا كان في ظل اطلاق النار مستمر
هذه السياره تعت اطلاق نار قبل ايام وادى
ذلك الى التقاء اربعه
شهداء